foreign
Forest
I don't look indigenous do I
your indigenous people always ask me but
don't worry I get that a lot
I bet you expected an exotic indigenous
woman with a painted face and feathers
in her hair
probably a bow and arrow too
well today I won't be talking about the
looks of indigenous people
today I want to talk to you about
indigenous perspective what that means
and how it can help save change this
world
so I come from Suriname the only
dutch-speaking country in South America
it is also known as the greenest country
in the world right now
you didn't know this now did you
Suriname is still 93 pristine forest
with a population less than 600 000
people
I come from the south of Suriname
near the border with Brazil and French
Guyana
I am from Amazonia I am wayana
I was born in a small settlement with
105 50 Waianae people
my start in life was complicated
you see
in our culture when your partner died
you had to wait at least two years
before you started a new relationship my
grandmother told me
when my father's wife died he decided
that he couldn't read anymore and took a
new lover
my mother
was at that time only 16 years old
and got pregnant
also sadly in our culture and maybe in
yours too
it is considered shameful
when you get pregnant and not living
with a partner
so because of that my mother tried to
abort me multiple times
well which as you can see didn't succeed
it did left me with some health problems
but I survived
my I was called for a very long time
which literally means trash
my father denied that he was my father
because of pressure from his family
but luckily my mother parents decided to
raise me
even so it was hard as I was constantly
treated as trash by the rest of my
community
so when I was five years old my
grandparents especially my grandmother
she decided that it was in my best
interest that I go to the capital of
Suriname to get an education to make
something of my life
so I packed my little suitcase
I stepped on a plane
with a family friend I barely know for
the first time in my life and left my
Village
I remember being determined at only five
years old that I was going to go back
to show them that I was more than trash
this family friend of my of ours and his
wife they became my foster parents
and I have been the second daughter that
my foster parents always wanted
and my foster family are from a tribal
people called samaka and they live as
indigenous people
here's the thing
even living far away in the capital of
Suriname going to non-indigenous school
surrounded by non-indigenous people I
was still indigenous
my world view and my DNA we are still
shaped by that Legacy by those tradition
because every summer holiday
I could go back to visit my grandparents
and learn those amazing cultural aspects
of being a winner
so yes I had the best of the Both Worlds
I have the best of both worlds and in
both worlds I was and I'm still
indigenous
what I came to realize is that even far
away in the capital
I was privileged to live in the greenest
country on Earth
because of indigenous peoples
because of indigenous guardianship
we are the Protectors of the forest so
we protect this world eighty percent of
all the world biodiversity is within
indigenous territories
let me repeat that in case you didn't
get that
80 of all the real biodiversity is with
an indigenous territories
the Amazon where I come from is more
home to plant an animal
species than any other terrestrial
ecosystem on this planet including
fourteen thousand forty thousand plant
species 2 200 fish
427 mammals
one in ten of the world bird species
live in the Amazon which has been
inhabited by indigenous people for
thousands of years
no
try to imagine
when non-indigenous people come to my
community to try to teach us about
sustainable Forest management our
conservation
we are the forests we breathe the forest
we cannot even translate sustainable
Forest Management in our own language
because to us it's simply a way of
living
we are the Protectors of the forest it
is because of us that the world has any
Force left to protect I believe we
believe that protecting the planet
should be done by indigenous people that
has been doing so all along
that is why the work that I'm doing with
my community is so important
I'm no longer trash I'm recycled
[Applause]
yes I'm recycled
um
the Amazon
where I come from
it's so unique and sometimes we as human
beings
we try to change things so fast and we
try to put our individual needs ahead of
our of the collective good
and because of this
change that's going too fast
we ultimately cause destruction that
will destroy us all
so today here I am to teach you guys how
you and I can protect this world the
indigenous way
what is indigenous guardianship
there are five key words that we can all
learn from from indigenous perspective
the first one is responsibility
responsibility towards
our territory where we have been living
along for thousands of years by taking
good care of it
we feel responsible for Mother Earth so
can all of you
demonstrate the responsibility through
action do not be afraid to say I don't
know let's find out together
attend activities hosted by indigenous
communities
lead by example
talk about decolonizing and indigenizing
education with colleagues
connect with indigenous people business
people
artists speaker and cross people in your
work and your life
learn about responsibility in the
context of our existence
the second R is respect
we need to respect each other just like
I respect your Western world you should
respect my world
respect
is a word
that is that is a concept that feels
often abstract than action based it can
be very difficult to find specific
examples
to demonstrate what respect is
we can all become guardians of this
world
respect
our way of living respect our knowledge
respect our way of decision making
respect our indigenous people cultural
Integrity it has worked for many
centuries
the third our responsibility is about
indigenous relationship that your
relationship is about indigenous people
relationship with their ancestral land
engaging with indigenous communities
is very important to understand the
nature of their relationship among
ancestral lands cultures and
spirituality
engaging in this way
requires long
long-term commitment and mutual learning
relationship based on mutual respect
eliminates the tendency to exert power
over and over it is something we can all
learn practice and improve
reciprocity
is the idea of embracing that giving and
receiving
connects people beliefs and action it is
not all about the money
and those who have resources
don't have all the power they shouldn't
have all the power
giving and receiving from the earth
endowments is also part of a virtuous
healing princip principle in this way
even the poorest indigenous Community
can give back to all of us
the last R redistribution
redistribution of our ancestral lands
my people for instance we don't have any
legal recognized land rights
because our ancestral lands have been
distributed to third parties as
concessions for Mining and logging
eighty percent of the world remaining
biodiversity is with an indigenous
Community as I mentioned before
and it is it includes
places that is essential for our global
climate
our fresh water
and food security
these are places vital to all of us
help in securing indigenous people and
rights join us support us in our fight
making sure that indigenous people have
the means to protect their lands
we can benefit all from that
make sure that indigenous people have
the economic power
and their cultural Independence so they
can be successful in protecting defend
and govern their ancestral territories
so
initially when my community threw me
away a stretch
they just thought that they were doing
what was right
they thought that they were doing
what was best because they learned those
things from Western power
Western Colonial powers and norms
and then they learn better they learned
that I also have important and in unique
values
and guess what
we're all doing the same thing with our
planet
we are throwing it away
we are trashing it maybe only for a
while because we didn't know any better
just to realize how much we all need the
Earth
because it uniquely contributes to our
lives and it sustains us
a healthier relationship
is key
a healthier relationship with indigenous
peoples is key to a healthier
relationship with the planet that we as
indigenous people
protect
and then we can all be recycled
and we can
Thrive and survive on this planet that
we call Earth thank you
[Applause]